even up the series the golden knights
back on the road tonight
game five set to get underway here in
just a little bit
sports director chris matthews landed in
denver a little while ago
he has hustled over there he is chris
are you ready for this and maybe more
importantly are the nights ready
well we think the nights are ready we
just barely got here so it's been
exciting now ballerina is going to be
full of about 10 000 fans here some
knights fans here but this team is
really really tough at home
they're 4-0 in the postseason they
haven't lost on this ice they have won
13 straight in fact if you go back even
further than that
they are 20 0-1 here all during the
whole season
then we lost four times here 22 4
and two so this team is really really
good on home ice but remember
in game two here the vegas gold knights
clearly outplayed
the avalanche for that second and third
periods and then in overtime they end up
losing so
vegas is confident they can play with
this team hey guess what we found some
vegas golden knight fans once again
here's mercedes and zoltan i appreciate
you joining us once again and
talk about this one you guys were here
for game two now you're back for game
five
the pesky post will not get us tonight
we'll get it
what do you think about this game here
tonight because they've been some great
games
well this is gonna be the biggest game
of the playoffs so far we have built
some momentum at home
and i think we can carry it over for
tonight's game you know how exciting was
the fortress for games two and three
amazing three and four i mean amazing
amazing hat trick
he won the lotto perfect night i know
he's the biggest lotto of the season and
he ends up winning that they're the
what is that the 59 49 or 51 49.9149
so now tell me how you think this game's
going to unfold here tonight
well i brought my lucky jersey so
i think i think it's going to follow
through with that and and we're going to
continue with that pace
now i can't even imagine if the golden
knights win this one how crazy it's
going to be on thursday for game six
exciting we're so excited to go home
well it's give me a prediction on the
game today and give me a go knights go
because i'll tell you what there's a few
knights fans here i'm gonna say three
two
three two i agree three two let's hope
they are right the
tan's uh once again out here in denver
turn go knights go
go go nice go go nice go
there it is reporting from ball arena
much more for you coming up at six
o'clock chris matthews eight sports now
back to you guys